this is Stuart Kimball speaking for Mark
Delaney the number of asymmetrical
horror games has risen dramatically over
the last few years with games such as
Friday the 13th dead by daylight Evil
Dead and more giving players the chance
to see the world through the eyes of
both original Monsters and licensed
slashers not to mention their hapless
victims no two of these games are the
same but gun interactive is one of a
very small number of Studios to work on
a second separate franchise within the
genre for the studio moving from the
Misty Camp Crystal Lake to the
oppressive Texas heat is an undertaking
that goes beyond setting and scenery
while some lessons can be applied
directly from one game to another a lot
more don't translate so easily despite
their broad Strokes being similar
Gamespot recently got to go Hands-On
with next year's horror game and speak
to the team about what it takes to bring
this specific series to video games what
it's like to become a go-to team for
horror adaptations and how they ensure
players appreciate playing as more than
just the series mass-marketed monster
with Friday the 13th there's one killer
with Texas chainsaw you're dealing with
a whole family the game plays in 4v3
matches where four victims notably not
named survivors but instead victims
awaken already ensnared by the slaughter
family that consists of The Hitchhiker
the cook and of course Leatherface
himself in the 50 years since the
original Toby Hooper movie shocked
audiences with its unflinching
portrayals of violence Leatherface has
outgrown his own Series in a way partly
due to marketing decisions Keltner
believes as slashers blew up in the
1980s Leatherface had become the series
mascot its face of evil who could stand
tall next to Jason Voorhees Freddy
Krueger Michael Myers and the rest but
the original movie was much more focused
on the family as a whole so in being a
recreation of sorts of that 1974 film
The Game does this too to match that
film you gotta have three family members
running around constantly on you making
you feel uncomfortable might this annoy
some players who really just want to be
Leatherface after playing it I think not
each killer has their own unique skill
set and they'll need to work together to
kill off the foursome of victims and
prevent anyone from escaping playing as
two of them I enjoyed them in different
ways thanks to how they bring crucial
abilities to the objective The
Hitchhiker is more Nimble so he can
crawl through small spaces and set
reusable traps like bear traps made
partly of bone that can be placed in
front of generators the victims will be
desperate to deactivate the cook is a
little slower and older but he can
listen closely and pinpoint the
survivor's locations even when they're
being very quiet Leatherface likely
needs no introduction but his
intimidating chainsaw also manages to
destroy obstacles that would give
victims some Breathing Room such as
clusters of furniture in a hallway or
even locked doors there's also a fourth
non-playable Family character the
rocking chair-bound Grandpa who villains
can feed blood from victims and enjoy
his sonar-like perks the victims can
sneak into his room and decommission the
immobile old man there's a difference in
balancing which is always a tricky word
to talk about when you're mentioning
asymmetrical horror Keltner said it's
not supposed to be balanced once that's
the definition of asymmetric right but
when you have three villains running
around what it creates is a far more
diverse gameplay and replayability in
Friday the 13th if Jason shows up and
he's a very aggressive brutal
in-your-face player then you kind of get
an idea of how the match is going to
kind of play out whereas in this you may
have two aggressive players and then
maybe one that's playing a little more
cheeky a little bit more stealthily or
however they want to play and that
formula changes each time because it's
all human driven we give you the tools
we give you the mechanics the abilities
to play the ways you want to play and
that makes for a rich type of gameplay
that every time you reset and everyone
picks different roles you feel that it
plays like a different game this novel
approach to the genre are giving the
killers nearly as many players as the
victims demands victims who feel
somewhat empowered as well but because
it's Texas Chainsaw Massacre this will
never be a power Fantasy on the map I
played getting off the property was the
only win scenario there are no cops to
call and Tommy Jarvis isn't gonna show
up with a shotgun like he does on the
campgrounds of guns pass effort each
victim has their own unique ability
however and like The Killers it's the
Tactical Confluence of all these
abilities that will lead to success
you'll need Connie's ability to
instantly open locked doors thus
bypassing the skill check minigame just
as much as you'll need Leland's ability
to lower his shoulder and knock villains
off their feet buying the group some
time both killers and victims have
linked these skill Trees Too it seems
though I wasn't able to explore them in
detail during my hour or so with the
game as usual in this genre the give and
take of deciding when to save an ally
versus when to write them off as dead
weight makes the Texas Chainsaw Massacre
an interesting social experiment on top
of its intentions of being a creepy
multiplayer game the map is full of
details that serve the gameplay for both
teams without breaking the illusion that
you're in a wretched hopeless place Gunn
wants players to feel like they're in
the movie themselves so the ample number
of locked doors small crevices used for
sneaking darkened Corners in the
grotesque basement and fast evaporating
Escape Routes managed to keep the house
grounded in reality without it feeling
too video gamey my favorite map details
are the open Wells outside the outdoor
space is pretty vast on the one of three
announced Maps I played but it's not
wasted space when you're being chased
for your life limping just out of the
reach of an assailant perhaps through
the sunflowers or around the shed you
can decide to quickly jump down into a
well but it's no salvation it leads you
back into the basement otherwise known
as Leatherface's Lair the decision to
escape to momentary safety by heading
back inside the house is truly the stuff
of horror movies rather than yell at the
screen when the protagonist does
something foolish here you'll realize
how necessary such a maneuver sometimes
can be the labyrinthine slaughter Family
household was reborn in intricate detail
as a horror buff I admit I found it
mesmerizing to move around that space we
can't see all aspects of the house so
easily in the movie since usually people
are running and screaming through each
section of it so the team has rather
painstakingly poured over the Aged film
frame by frame to ensure the game's
Recreation of that space is authentic
the other day I told developers hey I
just saw approximately like four frames
of the film there's a light switch at
the top of the stairs in this location
executive producer Ismail Vikings told
me and we'll go ahead and we throw that
in there the team is comprised of horror
nerds counting their added who described
at Great Lengths to which gun included
the faithful chainsaw audio we located
the make model and year of the Palin
chainsaw we found two or three of those
got Parts rebuilt it got it running and
then captured all the sound of that
exact saw
we hired Watson Wu who is a
world-renowned sound effects and Foley
artist and were assured that we got the
exact sound of that saw these small
touches are part of why Gunn has been in
contact with around a dozen different
horror franchise rights holders Keltner
revealed sometimes it's like one movie
studio that comes to me and they send me
a PDF that has like 60 something IPS on
it and they're like pick one and I'm
like that's not how this works adding
that the team is meticulous with whom it
collaborates seeking Partners who both
understand video games and will be
appropriately generous with the way that
a team can use the IP we have seen more
and more of these asymmetrical horror
games come to the market but it's not
how gun interactive is as a studio we're
highly selective on who we choose to
work with and what games we want to
bring to the market and they kind of
have to pass the sniff test here
internally noticing and appreciating the
game's finer details that have helped
grow Gunn into a horror name brand in a
short time span will take a lot more
playing than I've had so far and no
doubt more playtime will likely reveal
pain points as well but it's worth
noting being that while Friday the 13th
was a fun but oftentimes janky game The
Texas Chainsaw Massacre already feels
much smoother with better controlling
characters more digestible objectives in
UI stronger animation work and a much
more detailed landscape it all comes
together thanks to the authenticity that
I expect will excite fans like me who
are always seeking new experiences in
video game horror a somehow still
underserved genre the first time I saw
that Infamous metal door or the red wall
lined with animal skulls I immediately
felt like I knew this place that was as
a player totally new to me faithful
video game adaptations of other visual
media can uniquely immerse players who
bring with them a level of familiarity
and for me today that means an eagerness
to get back into that house despite
knowing the horrors that wait within it
foreign